why do you say to stop chasing your
dreams
okay i think you're referring to
um
like a vlog that i made right
well
i think later in life i realized that
the idea of chasing your dreams was
something
that
sort of made me unhappy because
you're always chasing after something
and if you don't achieve it then you
feel like you failed or you're not
getting fulfillment
but what i realize at least for me
is not about the achievement of some
grand
dream or you know
making a an incredible film or anything
it's like the process of
making films being creative that's what
made me happy and that's why i started
making films in the first place and i
think like halfway into that i kind of
lost track of that
because i started focusing more on you
know the awards or what
external factors were you know
seeing me as
um so i think when i made that video it
was my way of telling myself to like hey
stop chasing after dreams just start you
know doing what you love and that was
telling stories and being creative in
whichever way shape or form
when did you stop chasing your dreams
when did i stop chasing my dreams
see that that's a complex question
because
i don't think i ever stop chasing my
dreams i think it's a constant process
of me
trying to pull back from this idea of
chasing after something
but there's always that aspect of it
that's there
and
[Music]
so i can't really say i stopped chasing
my dreams but i've started to try
to
i guess live my dreams if you want to
say it that way i want to live my dream
and my dream has changed my dream is not
to you know be standing up on stage
winning the oscars or anything
you know even though i fantasized about
that when i was younger
now it's more like hey what can i do now
just to get creative fulfillment to be
happy what in what i'm doing
and as long as i'm doing that then
i'm living my dream already
do you think there's some a danger in
maybe what we've been fed about you know
reaching your goals and
you know you can be a success and it
puts too much pressure and maybe
um it's actually deflating
yeah definitely definitely i think just
the society in general like western
society the culture
has so much focus on
success and and what that is right most
of the time we associate that with
materials
material wealth like making money or
getting awards
and i think and i've seen this happen to
a lot of people around me like people i
knew
where they get burnt out from chasing
after these successes and outside
validation
and it's just not good for mental health
you know
so yeah
and you grew up around the tech industry
correct so you probably
saw you know i mean who who wouldn't
want to start the next whatever
and and be ringing the bell at the
nasdaq you know and have everybody um
cheering you on
yeah yeah i mean i grew up in cupertino
so the birthplace of apple computer
steve jobs went to a high school like
right next to my high school homestead
and yeah i mean i saw that through the
dot com boom all the way until
um until now
it's uh
it's just not
in my opinion it's not um
[Music]
a great way to live
so yeah
what did success mean to you when you
were making your first feature film
i think for me
personally at that time success at that
point was what
i had been fed
my entire life which was
make a lot of money
be a famous director that's what my idea
of success was
um
but when i made my first film
i didn't really have that
goal of like being successful
so although my idea of success was
something else when i made that film it
was really just to make that film and
tell that kind of story because it was
something very personal to me and it was
something that i hadn't seen before
in you know movies or in the media
really
so that was my goal for that film so
those two are separated
and what was that first film um my first
film was a movie called bang bang
what was it about it's a it's kind of
like a
thing of like the asian american version
of boys in the hood so it's like an
asian gangster movie
but not with triads it's more about
street gangs
and it's about
these two friends
who
one kid comes from a rich family and the
other kid is um
from a poor family but he's in the gang
and the rich kid wants to join the gang
and be a part of that lifestyle whereas
the the um the gangster kid wants to get
out of that lifestyle and he wants to
become a dj and pursue creative path
but you know their two paths kind of
you know break apart their friendship
and there's all this drama that happens
along with that
and that was shot where
oh we filmed that in san diego
okay but it was supposed to take place
in san diego um i didn't really wanted
to have a specific place that it was um
you know taking place in
but
it definitely has like a west coast kind
of feel
um so a lot of people actually recognize
the locations um and they're like oh
that's san diego this is where i grew up
but yeah yeah yeah it's always an
interesting mix of and i've seen that
before especially if you know in the bay
area there's a lot of great wealth but
you'll see the
few people that actually maybe are
almost ashamed of it and and sort of
want that street life and then of course
you know people that don't come from
that always envy
the opposite so yeah it's an interesting
uh interesting mix yeah
what does success mean to you now
success now
is really just about you know living a
a peaceful life uh um
a happy life
and not necessarily chasing after
wealth or um
you know material things and that has a
lot to do with um like a few years ago
i kind of got
um you know introduced to buddhism
and some of the ideas and philosophies
behind that um you know i went to
meditation retreat
and kind of like woke me up a little bit
in terms of like what's actually
important and what and what am i really
doing you know in this world
so now it's really just about hey
just keep your mind balanced and um
and do good things for other people help
other people as long as you're not
putting anything bad into the world then
you know
you're leading a good life
was there a certain moment you don't
have to go into personal details but
where you said you know i'd like to find
something in this world to kind of hold
on to that has more meaning than just
material value or how many views i get
on
whatever video
[Music]
yeah yeah definitely um i think
for me
i'm trying to pinpoint the exact time
i think you know like
there was a point where my third movie
um las vegas story um when it came out
and it didn't really
do that well like it was pretty much a
flop although i had thought that i was
gonna get this distribution deal and all
this stuff
and when it didn't happen
um
you know i think i kind of went into a
dark place
and you know at this time i was also
trying to
figure out some other things in my life
i think this is like when i was in my
late 20s
which i think for most people they do go
through that transition of like figuring
out what they want right um but yeah at
that point that's when i started really
questioning like
is chasing after success and and what is
success for me and why am i doing that
um and and who am i you know a lot of
these like questions
and then that's what led me to search
outside and you know
like i think i just picked up a random
book
once and it was like deepak chopra's um
what was it the mind body and spirit
and then uh yeah somehow it spoke to me
and then from there it was like one step
at a time kind of got a little more into
you know spiritual stuff